hey guys jake here coming at you with
another elden ring video and and today i
wanted to
just go completely off script i usually
make a script for my videos but but
today i just i just wanted to talk about
elven ring and i played this game a lot
over the last month i've put a
ridiculous amount of time into eldon
ring to say the least uh just over 200
hours in the game now i have completed
the game three different times with
three different totally different builds
totally different experiences it's to a
point where like i i got to apologize to
to my friends that i've been neglecting
over the last month like i've the only
game i've been playing lately is eldon
ring and whether it's that i love making
content for it especially here on
youtube and it's just it's so good
that's that's the best way i can put
this game this is the best game i've
ever played
i think you're doing a massive
disservice to yourself not giving this
game a chance and a lot of people have
given this game a chance actually that i
never thought would give eldon ring a
chance some some of my best friends have
been giving elden ring a shot uh who
have never played a souls game before
never played any of the dark souls
bloodborne shakiro never even gave it a
shot and if they did they didn't like it
because it wasn't accessible um and they
give eldon ring a shot and they're
they're loving it dozens of hours in the
game as well which um i'm so happy for
and they're telling me that they love it
it brings uh it fills my heart because
i've been a huge fan of the from
software genre the souls genre the souls
series since 2016 and that really isn't
even that long for for most souls
veterans i i started with dark souls 3.
didn't think i'd like it heard it was
good gave it a shot and i've been i've
been in the genre now for six years
which is uh i'd say in the middle of the
pack it's more than most not quite as
much as people have been playing the
game since demon souls back in i believe
is 2009 2007 i'm not sure back in the
ps3 days i i just didn't have a ps3 and
didn't give it a shot and i never even
heard of dark souls back in the day i
was playing call of duty to think i'm i
came from call of duty and fps shooters
to rocket league to playing elden ring
as the the main content that i want to
make for my career is it's cool i just
can't stop playing the game i can't stop
playing it because it it never stops the
game is so incredibly vast there's so
much to do that i'm over 200 hours and i
don't think i've found everything in the
game there's no way i have every new
playthrough that i've gone through with
the game i think i'll find everything my
first playthrough just under 60 hours
about 58 hours which is quite fast to to
beat the game i wouldn't even say i beat
the game i didn't even find melania in
my first playthrough i didn't know where
she was i never found her i'm like where
i saw this cool looking chick with a
long sword in the trailer and i never
found her and then i did my second
playthrough i was like oh there she is
there's so many secret areas in this
game that are absolutely gorgeous on top
of the main game being beautiful i've
never played a game this incredibly
detailed every foot of this game is
beautiful in my opinion a lot of people
say the graphics are you know are not as
good as last of us two or god of war and
i like to argue that because this is
clearly an art style this is not the
peak pinnacle of graphic fidelity in
elden ring this is an art style that i
think rivals those games in its own way
it doesn't have to look completely
realistic in every way when i look at
this game i think it's beautiful it's
like i'm looking at a painting when i'm
looking out at the vast open world that
i that i can go to any foot of the world
that i'm looking at and i think it's
beautiful that is an accomplishment in
and of itself uh like i was saying the
game never stops i originally thought
that the game was going to be about the
size of limb grave that we got maybe a
little bit further on and during my
first playthrough i'm like wow this game
is incredible i can't believe how big it
is it's not done it it goes further than
i
ever could have imagined i i can't
believe how big this game is it never
stopped you know at one point i got past
stormville castle and i looked out at
the the openness of everything that i
could go out and explore and i was i was
stunned i couldn't believe it i i was
worried that they showed too much in the
uh in the demo in the network test i was
like man they seem to be showing a lot
of this game i hope they're not you know
spoiling the vast majority of the game
for us and what they showed in the
network test might be five percent of
the game maybe maybe a little bit more
maybe ten percent game is huge with
things to do everywhere there's vast
cave systems there's all kinds of ruined
buildings and churches and castles a
variety of very interesting areas like
limgrave going to caled going to volcano
manor going to the academy lorena lakes
through the mountaintops to the capital
city and and so many other beautiful
hidden areas in this game i i still
can't believe it 200 hours in this game
and i'm still
blown away a month after release i'm i'm
still blown away by the size and scope
and vision of this game and the biggest
thing that i could point out about eldon
ring that i think keeps me playing it is
that when i'm playing elden ring and i'm
looking at the world i can tell how much
effort and love has gone into the
production and development of this game
the developers love what they're doing
and i think they've raised the bar for
the video game industry as a whole
because lately we've been getting dog
[ __ ] video games and here and there i
enjoy some games but over the last
probably three four years games have
been bad they truly have you know
they're these free-to-play games with
tons of micro transactions and an
unfinished product with tons of bugs
exploits cheaters with elden ring you
don't get any of that [ __ ] no
transactions you pay your upfront 60
bucks for your game and you have a
completely finished product which is sad
to say that that's rare nowadays it's
just a good
game and anyone telling you that it
isn't a good game just is butthurt that
they aren't very good at the game which
can happen or they don't know what a
good game is they've been brainwashed by
these free-to-play games that just give
out tons of content over a long period
of time but never give you a finished
good loving product and another example
of how from software has just been
giving us a special case with eldon ring
over the tons of games that have come
out over the last few years is they
don't hold your [ __ ] hand just like
all the from software games haven't held
your hand they don't tell you what to do
they don't tell you where to go they
give you everything you need to make
your own decisions you know most of the
time we have a quest log or a checkpoint
map telling us exactly where to go to
progress the story in in most of these
games elden ring doesn't do that you
open the door and you have a free open
world to explore you can go anywhere you
want you can discover anything to your
heart's desire you know you see that
cool building or that cool looking area
out in the distance go over there you
can absolutely do that now you might
come across uh some enemies that are
probably more that you can handle at
some points in the game but you have the
option to just leave you know most from
software games like dark souls 3 all the
dark souls games actually you're given a
boss and you have to beat your head
against the wall until you beat that
boss and then you can progress and
that's still the case in this game you
can absolutely bash your head into a
wall as much as you want and uh and be
the boss at level one as much as you
want you can absolutely do that but
they've made elden ring so accessible to
new players to to get in the genre who
don't want to bash their head against
the wall you have the option to do that
as well you have summons that you can
call upon to help you in these boss
fights you have really generous
checkpoints with the statues of marica
with the sights of grace that are all
over the map with fast traveling with
horseback riding with torrent getting
places much faster you have builds and
leveling to to make your character
exactly the way that you want you have
crafting and items that you can use
against certain bosses that can give you
an advantage they've made the game
accessible to all types of players which
is why i think it's been a massive
success over the last month you don't
have to cater to every single person and
make it a brainless easy game or put an
easy mode in this game to make the game
easy there's more creative ways to do
this than just adding a menu option from
hard to easy you know doing that is
honestly uncreative you just make the
ais stupid they do less damage you do
more damage and and call it a day that's
not creative you can be more creative
than that and that's what they've done
in eldon ring they give you all of the
options to make the game easy if you
want it to and they respect you enough
as a player they think you're smart
enough to be able to deal with it and i
think this game shows that some people
aren't capable of doing that they don't
know what to do when they're given so
many options which you know for some
people that's fair they don't come to a
video game to think very hard and that's
fine they can go play another game or
you can make a build in summons and and
all kinds of things that you can do in
elden ring to make it the experience you
want it's it's completely accessible and
anyone saying that elden ring is too
hard is it just not i know it's hard to
say that a player can play a game wrong
but that's just what you're doing you're
playing the game wrong
i don't want to say that because it
seems extremely harsh but you just don't
understand and if you can't understand
it with elden ring you're not going to
understand it with any of the rest of
their games because these games are so
[ __ ] incredible and i want to see
more people play these games i've been a
huge fan every souls game and i'd love
to see my friends play more of those
games and i've seen that my friends will
go play elden ring and they're like man
is it as good as dark souls 3 and it's
like you should go give it a try go try
bloodborne go try sakiro all the dark
souls games go give them a shot now that
you sort of understand how this game
works you know i think a lot of people
have been sort of brainwashed a little
bit by the gaming industry just
constantly holding your hand giving you
a [ __ ] store or you can go buy all
the [ __ ] like you know pay to win
[ __ ] to make your experience the way
that you want it just by paying money
how about we put it in the game how
would we make it a little bit more
creative and and from software is so
confident in the game that they've made
here with elden ring that they hide some
of the best areas in this game in a vast
cave system or a really intricate and
detailed quest line that you have to go
through to even find these areas you
know how confident you have to be to
hide your best content from the player
that i didn't even see in my first
playthrough i had to play through it
again to even find it that takes some
balls that takes some guts and they know
their game's good they're proud of it
and it shows it shows on this game it
shows in the art shows in the gameplay
it shows in the combat it shows in their
level of detail it's just a [ __ ] good
game man like i said you are doing
yourself a massive disservice as a gamer
if you are a gamer of not playing this
game you absolutely should give it a
shot i love it it's the best game i've
ever played hands down not to mention
the the story a lot of people are taken
back by the story of all of these souls
games because they don't feed it to you
through tons and tons of dialogue in
fact there's barely any in any of these
games any of the souls games or even
elden ring i'd say there's a lot more
dialogue in elden ring than most souls
games but again it's from software
there's so they're going to be very
vague on how they tell their story and
again i think it's because they're
confident in their environmental
storytelling they don't tell you the
story like i said through the dialogue
they show it to you in the world that
they've created and all of the detail
that they put in every single area every
foot of this game is detailed and
intricately woven into the story into
this world that miyazaki and george rr
martin have created for us it's
incredible and you know what i
appreciate it i might be one of the few
that appreciates a a good game when it
comes out because like i said we don't
see that [ __ ] often we really don't we
don't see love put into a game very
often anymore most of the time we see
companies just trying to make as much
money as they can out of their game and
it's not to say that elden ring hasn't
made their [ __ ] money but they've
made such a good game here that i am a
lifetime fan anything that this company
puts out from now on i'm going to buy
because i know i'm going to get a
quality product from them and i can't
say the same for a lot of other
companies out there a lot of other video
game developers i can't say that any dlc
that eldon ring puts out i'm gonna buy
it immediately i won't even give it a
second thought any new game that they
put out i'm gonna buy that immediately
you know how hard that is to do for a
developer that has to be the number one
key for your success as a video game
developer you want people to play and
buy your game as much as possible and
boom they did that not through all the
other [ __ ] that most gaming
developers do with micro transactions or
an unfinished product uh pushing out
updates you know months and months and
months over end until it's finally
finished and most of these free to play
games are never finished rum software
did it by just making a good game and i
will say the marketing for elden ring
was [ __ ] incredible i saw it
everywhere before the game came out they
killed it eldon ring is a masterpiece i
recommend it to everyone if you're a
gamer if you're not a gamer play this
game there's just so much here so much
content like the title says i'm 200
hours into this game i don't see any end
in sight i haven't even touched pvp yet
which i've heard there's some you know
balancing issues with the weapons and
it's not to say that there's not
problems with elden ring but when you
make a game with this much effort and
love i i look past you know the [ __ ] i
look past the glitches i look past the
balancing problems of weapons and pvp
and even in pve i look past that [ __ ]
because you made something special here
and i appreciate it and i want them to
keep making games like this please from
software don't ever stop and they've
even said that they they make hard games
they make good games and they're that's
the core of what they do and what they
are and they are not going to stop and i
can't wait for more content to come out
in this game i can't wait to keep
playing the game i can't stop it's just
too good of a game thank you guys for
watching i hope you enjoyed me just
rambling about this game i just had to
get all this out because man i think you
really are doing a disservice to
yourself not giving this game a shot
thank you for watching i'll see you all
in the next one peace and love